well luckily for all of you I played it
in another tournament maybe not lucky
for me but someday my opponents will get
lots of rating points this was the club
championship somehow I tied for first do
two terrible failures of the other top
players in the last round I hope they're
hanging their heads in shame still I was
expecting the tie for third but somehow
the higher rated players decided that
winning was unfair so I was a three-way
tie for first even though I didn't play
the last two rounds because I was busy
making lectures for all of you at home
okay so this was my second round game
which was actually the third round
because I had an accelerated schedule
actually this was the second round let's
see what did i do i took a bye in the
end I take bison ends of tournament at
the beginning I can't remember this
actually was round two this was against
a chess club member and get about town
Matt Barrett okay and hopefully and the
airing of this video on YouTube he's
still alive okay
and we played a Sicilian which is all of
my students know is not only my favorite
opening but my favorite pizza speaking
of pizza yeah I heard Claudio got a
pizza from down the street today and it
was good although my camera thought the
price was a bit was a bit pricey okay
whatever texts about this lecture Wow
it is about this lecture that's pretty
good okay so when I play this Sicilian I
would say about half the time I face the
open Sicilian and the other half either
c3 or Bishop b5 and this game my
opponent played Bishop b5 now I always
play nice c6 because that's what I do
although you can also play d6 e 6 or g6
and even though I always play knight c6
I've also played a 6
so I guess I'm a lawyer too okay so 96
now hear my opponent play Bishop b5
obviously he wouldn't play that move I
applied a6 and if he had pre moved
okay so Bishop b5 in this position
there's two common moves for black and
they have different middle game
strategies who can raise their hand and
suggest what the two most common moves
are for the black pieces here we'll call
on a random student Danny 94 is illegal
Knight d4 which is I don't know the
fifth most common sixth I don't know
fourth let's call a real chess player
Richard pointer right is one of the two
most common and can he do it after two
years is it possible that the answer is
no yeah
two beers is too many okay so e6 is a
very common move and the other common
move possibly more common is g6 okay and
probably at the very top level g6 is
slightly more common but I play e6 now
the reason I play certain openings and
certain variations doesn't have a lot to
do with you know studious thought it has
to do with random things that have
happened in my chest career one of those
random things was I was playing in the
New York open I even before New York was
called New York that's how long ago the
tournament was and I had the white
pieces in this position
my opponent played east six and they
totally crushed me and I was like wow
that's a good move so I started playing
e6 a and I like E six my play with white
was was not the best okay so my opponent
castled which is probably what most
people do and the point of e6
is to play ninety seven and if white so
chooses to capture on c6 we can
recapture with a nine
now you may be asking or wondering why
did in black take right away even though
it's white why didn't white take right
away
a and ruin your pawn structure okay and
actually that's a very common move also
you take towards the center and the
strategy for black is very unusual here
you would expect blacks going to play d5
at some point but actually the strategy
for black is to play 97 96 and to play
e5 and after playing e5 I often play d6
Bishop e7 castles and f5 and that's
actually the game that I lost in the New
York open something like 1985 okay and
I've actually had this many times also
okay most of my opponents don't take on
c6 but that's interesting because you're
rooting your opponent's pawn structure
okay so castles 97 now as I've said in
many previous lectures but you probably
weren't there because they were probably
lectures for children if it was bughouse
white should play Knight to d6 checkmate
so I don't plug this variation in
bughouse you're too risky okay and my
opponent here made a move I've never
faced before and I face every move it's
a very strange contradiction
I've had people play C 3 I've had people
play rook e1 I've had people play Knight
c3 I've had people play b3 and I think
I've had people play d3 but my opponent
played d4 and this is sort of a
contradiction of what white wants to do
in the opening now I'm sure all of you
are familiar with the game Carlsen
versus mvl which was played I believe
yesterday what day is today Tuesday two
days ago in the London chess classic
playoffs and in those playoffs we also
saw Bishop e5 in the Sicilian and one
idea for white is to put his pawns on
white squares and his white square
bishop is entrapped back here but it
gets traded off you get sort of a
Marazzi vine position which is what
Magnus did so when you play Bishop b5 in
the Sicilian you don't always play d4
although Magnus
eventually did you're either not playing
the open Sicilian or you are and here my
opponent did both and this is a very
unusual move because if he wants to play
the open Sicilian it's very strange to
put the bishop here when these other
pieces have squares they can go to and
the bishop I think has better squares
than b5 where it's going to get traded
off so I didn't know the move d4 pretty
early in the game and afterwards when I
looked at my database it turns out this
is the fifth or sixth most common move
so I am okay now this is something I see
a lot from lower rated players the game
goes efore a5 or in this case e 4 C 5
and when their opponent plays d4 as my
opponent adhere they don't capture it
well the reason you're playing E 5 or C
5 on move one is to prevent d4 if we go
back in this position if white could
move again white should play d4 because
that's a good move and in other openings
where black allows d4 white plays d4 for
example in the Carroll con white plays
d4 then in the French white plays d4 if
black plays this white would probably
look like d4 at the Grandmaster level so
when you don't want your opponent to
play d4 and you play move like c5 now
you're going to take on d4 when your
opponent does play d4 then you should
capture it otherwise they have a pawn on
d4 so wipe-on plays d4 even though I
don't know the move excuse me in this
exact position I'm still going to take
on d4 otherwise d5 is annoying so we
traded and now I had a long thing and
after my thing I kept Reed we guessing I
kept second-guessing myself that I was
playing the wrong moves and thought
other moves were better but actually I
was playing the most common and the
computer moves so sort of lucky I could
play a6 attacking the bishop I could
trade for the knight make its Queen move
up but I decided to play Queen
v6 which puts pressure on both of his
pieces and it turns out this is the most
common move and when my opponents hook I
had many many ways to capture now I
showed this in a kid's class to Sunday
and I was showing them all the captures
you could take either way with the pawn
you could take with the Queen or you
could take with a knight and one of the
kids raises in and explained that I had
missed the capture I did indeed miss
Queen takes after you check okay
so kids see things that I don't okay
also I don't think I mentioned Queen
takes then although maybe I did well
when I play Queen b6 my intention was to
take but I changed my mind and I decided
to play D takes because I thought that
was the least like something that he
would have prepared and it turns out
even though this is like the third most
common capture it is recommended by
stockfish six so it's not as bad as I
thought it was and when I played the
move my opponent was not at the board
then I was thinking there was a dumb way
to recapture so I actually decided that
was a bad move after I played it but
thinking isn't my strong suit so it
turns out it was a fine move now the
reason I play D takes c6 is if I play
the normal move B takes is the most
common it's very hard to get my Bishop
out and once I play D takes my plan was
to play e5 get a symmetrical type
position except my opponent is going to
move his Bishop a lot and has no
development so I wasn't really worried
about the symmetrical position the only
thing I'm worried about when I play e5
is my opponent might play f4 and start
attacking me because my king is on ei
but since f4 is illegal I was less
worried about it again however the
reason I decided this was a bad move
when I was playing later to change my
mind again is because the Queen can be
harassed the Queen can be in her asked
by the White Knight by moving either to
a3 or g2 and finding a good home on c4
and once Knight c4 is played my queen is
attacked 96 check as a threat
and I hadn't seen that idea when I had
recaptured I just randomly assumed my
opponent would play Knight c3 because in
the open Sicilian white usually plays 93
so my opponent retreated his Bishop and
I played Knight g6 so I could play e5
and get my Bishop out somewhere and I
was expecting Knight d2 to c4 lucky for
me the computer says that's about equal
it says 92 he 594 attacking my Queen
Queen c7 and I was a little bit worried
the knight would go to f5 but my knight
can go to f4 so I probably shouldn't be
worried anyway computer says it's about
equal I was very pleased
my opponent played Knight c3 a very
natural looking move but a move that I
thought was a big mistake
but the computer engine says it's a tiny
mistake I think the computer engine
doesn't understand the position as well
as I do but it calculates better than I
do and the reason I like Knight c3 is
the knight really doesn't have anywhere
to go
McKay go to e4 due to illegality it
doesn't want to go to these squares and
94 seems a little silly so the Knights
not really good on c3 in fact when I
play the movie 5 which I think I did now
yeah now we have a symmetrical pawn
structure except when you see a pawn on
c6 and a knight on c3 it's very
advantageous to the pawn because the
knight can't go to d5 or b5 where as
eventually I can go to the d4 square and
if my opponent wants to kick me out of
d4 he'll have to play c3 well why is his
knight on c3 now my opponent play what I
thought was a good move but he didn't
know why he played it maybe he's better
than I thought and after the game I said
why didn't you go here he said I can go
there so he had a good reason for his
move he didn't know it was okay now here
my Queens on his b2 pawn so if he moves
his Bishop anywhere I'll take this pawn
and he played a very tricky move a3 and
the purpose of a3 which my opponent
didn't know was to move out his bishop
and when I played the
move Bishop e7 instead he played b4
which is not a good move that extra
reminds me of the old Anand which
funnily enough would be the young Anand
and the young anon which is a better
player than the old Anand was a much
worse positional player but a better
tactician which is more important so if
you're taking notes old Anand equals
young Anand young Anand is worse but
better okay and before obviously I'm not
going to play Queen takes b2 but as I
explained after the game of my opponent
why didn't you play Bishop to e3 and he
didn't realize that his move a3 was
better than he expected because if I
take the pawn on b2 he'll play Knight a4
and my queen is embarrassed it's so
embarrassed we're going to put it in red
pretty embarrassed right would have been
better if I put in red originally but
okay and well he didn't see that he
could play Knight f4 after Queen B - so
he was still expecting that Bishop to e3
lost to pawn now in this position if you
play Bishop to e3 and I take your pawn
not only am i attacking your knight or
maybe the Knights attacking the Queen
how about what do I know the Queen also
has to escape squares b4 + a3 which to
move a three eliminates so now he could
play Bishop e3 and I was going to play
Queen to c7 okay positions about equal I
would rather have black because you know
his knight can can't do anything and
eventually I'm going to play rugby and
attacking his Queen the Queen doesn't
really have a great square and it's
really difficult from the play f4
because I have three pieces defending f4
so even though the pawn structure looks
symmetrical and it looks equal to me
it's just nice for black because white
doesn't really have a good plan okay my
opponent played b4 which is very
weakening and I castled now I made a
really interesting move he didn't play
Bishop III by Bishop c4 first and the
idea is just to prevent my Bishop from
moving Bishop d2 is risky
because he can capture it this ship f5
Bishop g4 and Bishop h3 also just give
the bishop away Metra Bishop e6 it's a
double-edged decision about these
doubled pawns here it's very nice for my
rook and my pawns do control a lot of
squares but it's hard for a black to
break through when these two pawns are
blocked by one so I decided to defend
the e6 square by playing the move Knight
f4 now the double pawns on the F file
would be fine if he trades for my knight
he's giving away all the dark squares
just have a dark square Bishop all these
dark squares are for the taking and my
pawn on e5 on the previous move was sort
of blocking my bishop but not F not
after he takes on f4 because now my
bishop has this beautiful f6 square and
I mean white would really want to move
his pawn back to b2 which I don't think
is legal although in some of the kids
classes okay so this this is a very good
position for black I have the two
bishops and my dark square bishop will
sue be a monster okay you could play e5
maybe you should play e5 although I
would be somewhat scared that eventually
I'm going to lose that pawn now you let
my other bishop get to a good square and
well probably five is the right move
maybe I would even preface the ship f5
with a five because you just have all
these pawns that eventually I might
capture I'm not really worried about
losing this pawn just because I have the
two bishops in the dark squares and you
have so many weak ones I can attack
thank after a5 I'm not sure where white
does cries well as you can see in the
game a5 really put a hurt on them later
manner the truth hurts the to the truth
yeah you don't want to lose everything
not against me again so let's see Oh
Mario
left against Mario he left if he was
here I would never say that never right
Richard
si defending everything I probably play
up three just to break my own rule ever
play f3 yeah yeah I don't know I'll take
I'm sure the computer says that that is
okay
you can't play 94 cuz you're e5 ones
hanging but maybe you can later yeah
right yeah if you could move again so
yeah this is a way of playing but I
think it's good for black okay my
computer also agreed luckily with me
that night f4 was the best move I would
guess your way of playing is far
superior to my opponents so don't play
me because you might win okay my
opponent attacked my queen and I moved
it back to c7 and he played Queen f3 now
a lot of players especially lower rated
ones like to move their Queen out as a
higher rated player I like to capture
your queen when you do that so keep
moving your Queen route far out so I can
take it and I mean the Queen is going to
have to leave d1 eventually because I'm
going to play rugby 8 and I don't really
see a good square f3 is probably as good
as any but I'm going to harass your
Queen later and your piece is going to
get all bottled up I played a5 as I said
I would and b5 looks like it loses
material since all the pieces on the C
file are hanging
you can't lonely let me take up on for
free so you played rugby one after the
game he thought maybe he should play the
other rip to be won but then this work
has overworked okay or as Richard would
say overloaded I would trade on b4 trade
on a1 and then there's a free pawn so
actually if he wants to defend his pawn
my thing rugby ones the way to do it
then I trade pawns and this actually
reminded me of how chess has evolved you
know over the last 150 years it used to
be you sack everything and play for me
right Danny okay and then people got a
little more sophisticated and they
started to get little advantages
Steinitz style although Steinitz before
he got his little advantages would sack
all these pieces for me
okay then players like kappa blanka
Petrosian smith Slav and Karpov to name
a few
we're very good at gaining small
advantages and they would add up to a
winning position I was actually thinking
that in this position okay and I think
my opponent was thinking Arby's but I
was thinking about advantages okay off
to ask if s/he was thinking one of my
advantages is this pot is weak and it's
under attack I don't really have any
weak pawns that can be attacked my
second advantage is my rooks on this
nice open wine and his rook is defending
a weak pawn and my third advantage is my
Knights really strong in his position
and his knight can retreat and it does
retreat so what Black has a lot of
little advantages that have to a good
position okay now I did something called
fixing upon okay it's not the beetle son
fixing a Hall so don't sue me okay well
you could sue me okay good luck
collecting and I played the move b5 now
it's difficult for White's that move his
be pawn again unless you're in my kids
class then they would probably go here
okay that my move would not work okay
maybe the kid should learn how to play
it all right and my opponent has to
retreat his bishop well if he retreats
to b3 then the b4 pawn is weak and just
to show you what I was thinking during
the game if black if white place for
tactics for example Bishop takes b4
Bishop takes f7 check now Danny's happy
because their tactics and the idea is
the rook is going to take the bishop I
was planning on actually playing the
move King eh-eh
I don't like my King on the same
diagonal as a bishop now I can play f5
later and I'm threatening to take this
pawn so my opponent played Bishop to e2
although his pieces are sort of jammed
up here they're sort of tripping over
each other
okay now this is a very tricky move
because if I play the obvious move rip
to a3 now white plays all kinds of
tactics he defends his tonight by
playing Danny's move Bishop takes f4
the Queen defends the knight and now he
could play something like Knight takes
d5 and I'm about 30 years too old to
analyze this position so if I go back at
a time machine 30 years then I could
analyze it or if I turn my engine on
okay and during the game I was thinking
oh if I take he takes this where he
plays Queen b3 takes this which is not
good for not good for black and if I
take his queen he takes my queen and I
was thinking well what if I move my rook
and I try to trap this Knight
well I can't really trap it because it
has a square to get out and it also has
a eight that was like I don't think I
can trap his Knight and I am down upon
so I didn't want to know eyes crazy
stuff like that what I already had an
advantage so instead of playing York a3
I developed my last piece Bishop to e6
and if you look at the e-file
you'll notice it's symmetrical
everything is the same the problem is my
Knights better than his my rooks better
than his and my B pawn is protected and
his isn't by a pawn so black has these
little advantages that add up to a big
advantage okay he played rook to e1 I
think he wanted to play Bishop f1 and
give his queen some space and it was
funny after the game ended this is the
second time in the game my opponent made
a move for a very good reason but he
don't know what the reason was so he's
going to be a grandmaster someday
because he doesn't know why he's playing
he's great news B still doesn't I played
the move Bishop to d6 and I have a
threat which my opponent didn't see but
he prevents it anyway pretty good pretty
talented okay so after the game he said
why did you play Bishop to d6 and I said
will you you prevention my threat you
must have seen he's like now so if black
could move again
what would black do why did I play
Bishop
2d6 I'm not going to bet on the two beer
guy that's not good
anybody have three beers you at home oh
they're drinking whiskey at home anyone
Bueller okay remember black hat black
white has a weak beep on which I would
like to capture so Bishop d6 means I can
attack that pawn again with what's that
Queen e7 and my queen of Bishop former
battery on the b-pawn and I don't see
how he defends it and if I take that B
pawn you're going to wish you didn't
play rook e1 so you know in this
position I was like how can I take
everything and I was like well I'm
already attacking this how can I attack
it again and I found Bishop d6 Queen e7
now hear my opponent defended his B pawn
but at what cost
as Bensimon would like to say would like
to say often says it's a Pyrrhic victory
for Wyatt because Pierce is your
favorite right yeah okay that's the st.
Louis school system for you okay and he
played the move Knight to d1 okay and I
assumed the reason he played Knight to
d1 was so that when I attack his bond he
could play pawn to c3 but it was
happenstance man saying the word
happenstance is very funny boy two
people in the world know Wyatt and I'm
one of them so okay I wrote an article
today for the newsletter use the word
happenstance and it was edited out and
put with a word that means something
else so yeah that's the the fox guarding
the hen house here alright so I played
rook a to because when the knight was on
c3 I couldn't play rook a to but now I
can okay and my opponent didn't want me
to take and play the move c3 okay so
white defended everything but the night
is on d1 and I learned something a long
time ago when you have pieces on d1 that
aren't rooks and Queens that's not good
I had a bishop on
one and that wasn't good and I lost and
now my opponent has a nighttime t1 and
that's not good that's not the most
active square and even though the pawn
structure is totally symmetrical white
is actually losing and whites losing
because almost all of his pieces can't
move this night on g1 is almost trapped
his riccati one is almost trapped his
Queen on f3 is almost trapped and I'm
dominating the only open file that's of
use the a file if I wanted the D file
get that too because his Knights on d1
and here I can take advantage of the
badly placed White Queen by possibly
attacking it okay but I need to make a
preparatory move I have to prepare to
attack it now the whole game when my
King was on ei I was worried that white
will play f4 which seems a bit silly now
I don't think white will play f4 that
would be incredibly illegal even for the
kids class even in the kids class they
wouldn't suggest F well some might but
I've really stopped him from playing f4
conversely I can play the same move with
black with decisive effect and that move
is louder f5 yeah and actually after f5
it's all over now the computer gives me
this monster evaluation even though
material is equal and the reason is I
have actual threats okay now when yes or
Sarah Juan lectures or does live game
analysis he's not really into actual
threats because that's not fair
actual threats is cheating that's more
of an Alejandra thing okay that's more
of a merese thing yes err likes to say
my bishops better than yours my rooks
better than yours my suits better than
yours
okay he's not in so like I'm threatening
your queen he doesn't do any of that
okay
computers on the other hand like to take
all of your pieces and when you asked
her was playing chess at his peak in the
80s and early 90s grandmasters weren't
giving all their pieces away okay unlike
certain people in this room when I say
certain people
all you so when you give all your pieces
away we take them well you don't give
all your pieces away now we have to
outplay you somehow that's what you
astral likes to do okay because yessir
is used to playing other grandmasters
and at the Chess Club I've used to
playing you so I get to take a lot of
pieces okay now in this position I'm
basically threatening to take your pawn
and if you take with a queen I have to
winning skewers so let's play a random
move
that's pretty random I can skewer your
queen and rook or I can skewer your
Queen and your G pawn and by the way the
White Queen doesn't have a lot of
squares to go to also it has none so f
Jake c4 is a serious threat and if you
take on f5 for example I could play
Bishop to d5 with this kind of skewer or
I could just take back on f5 with
anything the bishop or the rook and here
I'm threatening your rook and I'm
threatening to play e4 which basically
trapped your queen okay and it's a
disaster okay now here he tried to
extricate himself from these
difficulties but was not successful
played the move rook to b2 and the idea
is I no longer have any skewers on this
diagonal and he's kicking out my rook on
a t2 he's like get out of there
okay and if we trade rooks and his
Knight goes to be to to recapture maybe
he can play Knight g3 and get rid of my
night because the knight on d1 is not
very good okay so I took on e4 and I
thought the best move was to play queen
g3 although well I think it is the best
move but okay black is still winning
blacks up material and White's position
is is awful his knight on d1 but usually
when somebody takes a pawn you want to
take back I think when you're playing
the world's best players something
Bensimon often does yeah all the time
you you get you know hit back with a lot
of great defense and your opponent makes
it difficult for you to win when you're
playing lower rated
players in your winning sometimes they
just fall apart it happens then here
after F takes e4 he he really fell apart
I mean oh he was losing so he sort of
expedited the process okay
do you play Queen takes e4 and why
didn't want to lose my rook
so I figured I'll trade rooks first this
is actually quite funny my opponent
didn't take the rook back which is what
I would do
okay and after 964 or b2 the engine
wants me to play Bishop to d5 and
capture this pawn and it says something
like +4 because White's getting
checkmated and getting crushed and the
knight is on B 2 but my plan was to play
Bishop f5 I only see one square for the
Queen and then e 4 again I only see one
square for the Queen and then Knight
takes check wins his queen that seemed
good so that was my plan in Maya plan
did not happen because my opponent
didn't play Knight takes rook
he took the knight on f4 causing total
confusion I'm up so much material now is
confused again again this actually
happens to me often at the Chess Club
I'm one of the few grandmasters who's
played the best and the worst okay most
grandmasters choose to play the best and
if you take someone like okay Vishy
Anand he's pretty good but a world
champion for many years all of his
opponents are quite good so Anand wins
about two games a year okay
I win two games a day because my
opponents aren't as good and an on isn't
used to being up six seven eight pieces
but I am because I play a lot of blitz
chess of the chess club in fact I played
several games of the Chess Club today
with no clock against one of the chess
club members and in one game I was up
about three pieces that nothing was
happening and eventually he was like
yeah I think I'm lost now when he had
been lost since move seven but he
realized down three pieces
and unavoidable meetin one now maybe
he's lost so the Chess Club I'm used to
being up tons and tons of pieces and my
opponents being oblivious probably a
phenom was playing he would be like why
is my opponent down a rook and a piece
and thinking everything's okay okay but
I have more experience than he does at
these things alright so I play rook
takes Bishop I'm not surprised that I'm
up a rock and my opponent just makes
moves and doesn't care doesn't surprise
me at all
okay and if my opponent loses Queen away
you will notice I'm up a rock so yeah
now in my life at certain chefs
tournaments occasionally we get a
reporter who is not a chess reporter and
asked chess questions and they seemed a
bit confused my two favorites are
somebody asked Stuart Rachel is my good
friend how good he was at chess and he
said I'm the best player in Alabama and
she was like wow the best player in
Alabama because he was like 13 and she
was shocked and he says well wait a
minute being the best chess player at
Alabama is like being the best hockey
player in Idaho okay he was trying to no
minimize and my favorite chess question
was if you were up five pieces against
the world champion how would you do and
the person here if you'd said I'd win
and they said no you would you don't
realize how strong the world champion is
okay so yeah I guess my opponent didn't
realize extra Brooke was pretty good
okay now it should cause more confusion
my opponent gave his queen away okay but
I've played a lot of you in this room so
I'm used to that you guys give your
queen away I take it now here I thought
better of it if I take the Queen which
is a fine move nothing wrong with that
that you take my rook I have a queen for
a ruck sounds good okay but I analyzed
another variation that wasn't taking his
queen and I ended up playing it because
somebody said possibly Lasker which last
sir I don't know I guess I'll ask her if
you see a good move find the better what
was it Alaska there's somebody yeah so I
found that move that wasn't pawn takes
Queen
I played rook takes e to I guess it was
a better move because my opponent
resigned okay well obviously I'm
threading the Queen still and I'm
threatening rook takes rook maid so
probably he should play rook takes rook
and then I take the Queen and he takes
the bishop here I also have a queen for
a rock but this seemed a lot easier and
it turns out it is a lot easier the
engine says dish' p5 now this is trapped
Queen d7 is sort of annoying and I don't
know I don't know what he does now okay
so actually this was a better version so
like if you thought I was cheating which
is a good way to think that you'd be
right because if somebody was cheating
they would play rook takes e to because
that's a better move than pawn takes
Queen okay so if I was using a computer
every move then I would play rip take c2
although the computer really dislikes a
lot of my other words so I guess I
wasn't cheating now if we can go back I
want to show you a tactical move the
computer suggested which I saw and the
computer said that I'm totally crazy it
didn't actually say my moves were it
said you been Feingold are totally crazy
actually my name at Bishop d6 which I
thought was a great move and forced my
opponent to play 91 to defend his beep
on the computer said is a terrible move
why would I play a terrible move it
proves I'm not using a computer I fooled
you all okay because a computer would
never play Bishop d6 because of the move
Bishop takes b5
I saw Bishop digs b5 and I'm like oh
that's stupid but the computers like
that's great so I would take takes
finally to any Machuca takes notice this
ship takes b5 now he's happy and after
all of these captures it says black has
the minimal list of advantages and I was
like I'm up a bishop so okay but the
computer likes all of whites pawns and
it likes the fact that whites not
getting crushed anymore basically I have
a bishop
I have to win a thousand moves computer
says black has a small advantage here
like point two point three whereas if I
don't play Bishop to d6 it says I have a
large advantage now this is why Karpov
is good and you guys are sitting in a
dimly lit room looking at chess game
when Karpov would slowly build his
advantages and eventually win which I've
shown in previous lectures he did make
tactical errors throwing it all away if
you watch football and I'm sure you do
you'll notice some teams they're gaining
5 6 7 yards of play and after 15 plays
they get a touchdown well if you keep
doing that it's possible after 9 great
plays or 10 great plays and you've
gained 70 yards that you fumble you
interception and it's all for naught
this happens in chess you build your
advantage slowly the computer says
you're a point one then point two then
point three then point for your pun
doesn't know what's going wrong then you
hang your rook and then you're losing so
when you slowly build your advantage and
you make a tactical mistake it all goes
away the computer said that's what I did
it said white black has a great game
yeah you play great this is g6 you're
terrible Bishop takes b5 and white
should drop okay I bought in flight
those days b5 so I look good but if I
was playing a super Grandmaster who for
some reason was playing really badly
with white so I don't know to to too
much to drink then they would have fled
this should be five year and it would
have been very difficult to win they
wouldn't have played 9 to d1 making
their pieces even worse they would have
taken their last chance that's why the
super grandmasters are good when they're
having a bad day and things aren't going
well if somebody lets them get a little
trick in because it's hard to see all
the tactics then they can play that
trick and they can get outplayed both to
the game but still draw a win in fact
the great poker player chip fries so I'm
sure you all familiar with when he was
alive because after he died he didn't
say very much but when he was alive he
said the reason I'm a great poker player
is it because of my age
everybody's a game is good my begin is
pretty good when I play badly
I still play pretty well and what other
people play badly and the day knows what
I'm talking about okay I saw Daniel
plays a game in round two and then I saw
his B game around three okay it is a
game he'd beat a much higher rated
player this B game he gave all his
pieces away and then said darn I didn't
win okay now of course maybe his a game
wasn't enough for that guy either we
don't know that again so Bishop d6 the
computer doesn't like and I saw them
with Bishop b5 but I was like he won't
do that that's terrible
but it wasn't as terrible as I thought
so a little hiccup in the game giving
white a chance but that's what I'm here
for I give you local st. Louis players a
chance then if you don't take it nobody
knows okay well thanks for coming to
mastering the middle game that's why I
let him take on b5 if I didn't it would
be grand mastering the middle game but I
made a little error and I'll see all you
guys next week